the White House has yet to comment on
Iran's stunning announcement about the
plane but president Trump is revealing
new details about what led him to order
the killing of Iran's top military
general the president now says Qasem
Soleimani was planning a large-scale
attack on several US embassies abroad
CBS News has also learned that the US
military tried but failed to kill
another senior Iranian official on the
same day in Yemen Ben Tracy is at the
White House with more Ben good morning
good morning so president Trump says he
had act quickly to kill sulemani without
notifying Congress to prevent what he
calls another Benghazi but the
administration's story about that threat
keeps evolving it was going to be the
Embassy in Baghdad in an interview on
Fox News Friday night President Trump
said Qasem Soleimani was planning to
blow up the US Embassy in Baghdad then
the president revealed more they have
large-scale attacks planned for other
embassies and if those were planned why
can't we reveal that to the American
people wouldn't that help me earth case
I can reveal that I believe it would
have been for embassies that is more
intelligence detailed than members of
Congress say they received in
closed-door briefings on Capitol Hill
this week probably the worst briefing
I've seen at least on a military issue
in the nine years I've served in the
United States Senate we left with
multiple important questions that were
still unanswered this was gonna happen
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo is
version of events is also changing first
he said this about the Iran Threat we
don't know precisely when and we don't
know precisely where but it was real
less than 24 hours later in the White
House briefing room Friday he was far
more definitive we had specific
emanation information on an imminent
threat and those threat stream included
attacks on US embassies . . so you were
you were mistaken when you said you
didn't know precisely when and you
didn't know precisely where no
completely true those are completely
consistent thoughts secretary Pompeo is
also now dealing with an iraqi
government that is demanding a plan for
american troops to withdraw from Iraq
the Iraqis are furious about the
airstrike
on their soil that killed sulemani
calling them a breach of their
sovereignty and security agreements with
the u.s. we are happy to continue the
conversation with the Iraqis about what
the right structure is president Trump
was asked about withdrawing US troops
from Iraq in that interview last night
and at first he said he's okay with it
but then he walked that back a little
bit and said that if US troops were to
withdraw he would expect the Iraqis to
pay for it Michelle all right Ben thank
you
you